mais
et si on faisait un petit tour dans les
profondeurs notre guide aujourd'hui
c'est mathieu mara you i les apnéistes
et il va participer au prochain
championnat du monde d'apnée en
profondeur du 20 au 30 septembre à
chypre j'ai été sélectionné dans la
discipline de l'immersion libre c'est ça
consiste en fait à descendre à la force
des bras sur la descente des sur la
rente est donc j'utilise pas de panne
c'est vraiment la propulsion et se fait
simplement à la force des bras sur une
corde
[Musique]
cette yvelinois originaire de ben
participe à ses deuxièmes championnats
du monde dans sa discipline c'est la
profondeur qui comptent pas le temps
passer sous l'eau et pour cette
compétition mathieu maraï ô combien
battre son record mon objectif principal
se sera l'immersion libre ma spécialité
et ce serait de dépasser les 100 m voilà
j'ai un record personnel
à 98 m
qui s'était déroulé en 2019 là j'ai fait
récemment 95 m avec finalement peu
d'entraînement et dans des conditions de
mer un petit peu difficile mais pour
participer à ces mondiaux l'apnéiste a
besoin de financement sans sponsor il
décide alors de lancer une cagnotte
c'est très coûteux parce que il ya des
entraînements il ya le matériel et tout
ce qui est lié au déplacement les
billets d'avion et
l'hébergement
la nourriture tout ça ça coûte beaucoup
d'argent mis bout à bout et c'est pour
ça que cette cagnotte elle sera d'une
grande aide pour l'instant 1800 euros
ont été récoltés sur les 5000 attendu
une somme encore peu élevé pour
permettre à mathieu mario de plongée
dans le grand bleu